all right vice president harris tonight
at the center of mockery yet again after
this bizarre moment during a white house
meeting earlier today with disability
activists where harris along with
attendees they went through their
pronouns and describe what they were
wearing
take a look
good afternoon i want to welcome these
leaders for coming in to have this very
important discussion
about some of the most pressing issues
of our
time i am kamala harris my pronouns are
she and her i am a woman sitting at the
table wearing a blue suit
okay and of course the day wouldn't be
complete without yet another rambling
word salad from your ever so articulate
vice president at least she's not
giggling take a look
the dog's decision and the
act of the united states supreme court
to take away
a constitutional right that had been
recognized
from the people of america
will impact a lot of people
and differently in some situations and
we need to be responsive
to these issues and also lift up the
voices of all people who will be
impacted in the way that they will be
impacted
all right of course bizarre verbal
blunders of the least of harris's
troubles as a new report lays out what
we've been telling you from day one
which is that even democrats are not
that impressed with the vice president
according to a new poll of a possible
2024 democratic primary harris polls in
sixth place behold behind biden
pothole mayor pete
gavin newsom and others and as i laid
out on the program last night you watch
mark my words here's a prediction etch
it in stone it's going to be gavin
newsom will be anointed the new anointed
one and the next democratic party and
media mob darling here with reaction
former florida attorney general pam
bondi along with fox news contributor
laura trump
i i don't even know where to begin so
laura the first time this ever was
brought to my attention
i am a woman i am wearing a blue suit
okay is
a
friends of mine
had a child go to brown university about
five years ago and it's orientation day
and then they'd walk around the
courtyard and would ask how would you
like to be addressed
and i'm like what
never quite heard about that before
i don't care if people you know feel the
need that they want to be described a
certain way i'll respect their wishes
but doing it this way with all the
problems this country has seems a little
frivolous to me
yeah just when you think that we've hit
rock bottom
kamala harris comes out and shows you
that you can actually go lower there
there is a lower rung to all of it and
you know i think a lot of people have
asked themselves are we regressing sean
as a society in america well here is the
answer to that question sadly it feels
like yes if you watch this video of
kamala harris and i think it's just
totally insane and a lot of people look
at this and totally roll their eyes
because to your point sean this is what
the people in the white house are
focusing on pandering and pronouns i
mean my goodness you just had senator
cruz on talking about the horrific
crisis at the southern border there's
the borders are right there we have
people dying every day at the southern
border people being sold like cattle um
you know into human trafficking it is a
horrific situation how about the
fentanyl epidemic that is killing the
youth in america kamala harris is
supposed to be heading up the charge for
all of that obviously went down to the
border one time forget about the fact
that we have 40-year high inflation
forget about the high gas prices forget
about the embarrassments on the world
stage and the failures there this is
where our government is putting the
effort and it is really sad and i'll
tell you one thing if i'm xi jinping of
china and i'm looking to overtake
america as the superpower of the world
and i see a video like this as absurd as
this is from the vice president of the
united states man i am pretty sure that
i'm on the fast track to overtaking
america and sadly sooner rather than
later you know i i guess this will all
pan out pam in the election we have a
midterm coming up in november that'll be
the first indication whether or not
people are happy with their policies i
don't see how they possibly could i
can't think of think of a single subject
where they've been successful
um now there's another level of this and
that is they they want to teach kids all
of this you know sometimes uh doctors
they make a guess whether a baby is a
boy or a girl that's the type of thing
that we've been reading that schools
want to teach kids in even first grade
for crying out loud but yet they can't
do reading writing math and science and
they don't know computers very well and
we spend more per capita than any other
industrialized country how does that
make sense
it doesn't sean and look what they're
putting in our textbooks you know in
florida we found they were putting in
our textbooks in elementary school math
critical race theory sexual gender
orientation questions it was
unbelievable in math books in my own
state so those books were removed from
the state of florida you know what laura
said about what's going on and by the
way it's not going on in just one or two
universities it's in almost every major
liberal university in this country and i
think kamala harris is just pandering to
the left as far left as she could can go
instead of focusing on the important
things that laura just talked about you
know i was with donald trump all
afternoon when he gave his policy speech
at america first policy institute you
know what she should be worried about
what's happening right here i'm in d.c
in her own backyard driving here tonight
to the studio as president trump said
there are ten cities everywhere d.c is a
different place than it was two years
ago she should be worried about homeless
people regardless of what their pronoun
is it's really unbelievable that this is
happening in our world right now our
republican party our slate of candidates
for 2022 they're some of the most
diverse we've ever had in this country
we're not talking about that what we're
talking about is uniting our country and
because they're qualified and bringing
people together not having to identify
what color blazer you're wearing that
that's absurd to me you know we we have
the worst educational system as i
mentioned laura and we pay more than any
other industrialized country we have
crime out of control and every big blue
state and every town every city in this
country defund nobel's not working wide
open borders as you mentioned ted cruz
gas prices record record high 41 year uh
inflation high and we'll find out
thursday if it's official if we're in a
recession although they want to change
the definition of a recession you would
think they'd work on on literally
salvaging the mess that they made
rather than focusing on pronouns
well i mean i think a lot of people
would heed that advice sean but perhaps
they've just given up at this point
because as you just laid out what have
the democrats contributed in any way to
americans that has been positive i mean
they have completely destroyed this
country on every front and by every
metric possible so maybe this is all a
distraction technique hold these cozy
little functions at the white house and
talk about pronouns in an effort to
distract americans from the reality of
their everyday situation which is dire
for most people at this point but i do
want to remind people of one thing as
bad as the democrats have been and as
confident i think as republicans are
heading into these midterms we can never
take anything for granted we have to
make sure that people get out and vote
and make sure you are voting for the
right people know who you're voting for
all the way down the ticket we can leave
nothing to chance last 30 seconds pam
laura's exactly right and there's down
ballot races that we talk about all the
time the district attorneys the mayors
all of these local races are the ones
that are going to change our country as
well as our congressional and senate
slate and that's what's so important for
our country right now the democrats are
not focusing on this they're trying to
become as left and progressive as they
possibly can be and we're going to unite
this country and i think everyone should
listen to donald trump's speech today
from america first policy institute
about the future of our country
all right pam thank you laura thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else